après trois mois de brainstorming des
propositions sont remises en ce moment à
la mise de l'enseignement supérieur
elles sont d'une prudence extrême alors
le gouvernement est il en train de
reculer sur un sujet majeur qui rentre à
l'université et pour y faire quoi
c'est la preuve que le gouvernement ne
tient pas ses engagements cette reculade
qui s'annonce sur la sélection
l'université
écoutez là je dirais que je l'avais dit
d'ailleurs sur ce plateau il fera très
attention avec le monde universitaire
parce que c'est un peu une un chaudron
bouillant et je crois que emmanuel
macron l'a peut-être se dit que bon même
si vous vous rire tous les fronts à la
fois c'est peut-être pas la peine
d'ouvrir celui-ci tout de suite entre
les apl la propagande de mélenchon dans
les universités la frustration liée à
l'échec universitaire on va en parler je
pense c'est à mon avis c'est une
population qui est beaucoup plus
susceptibles de bouger
est ce que je veux dire pour qui s'en
méfient que le monde ouvrier sud